uh look at this new york times uh writes
a guide to neo pronouns
are you a person place or a thing we
have good news
um we're all persons yeah yeah are are
you a place
well hold on here i'm a place so this
image there this is the new york times
mind you
it's an image and it's the new york
times yeah pre
print prince and print self
no no no and go f yourself well hold on
hold on hold on
if someone there there are some
limitations if someone came to me and
said referred to me as your majesty or
prince whatever i'd be like
would you refer to me as lord no i'm a
scottish lord
yes i bought ten lords ten foot by ten
foot
square of land i'll i'll use whatever
preferred pronoun someone wants i have
no intention to be rude i'm not
interested in
in in upsetting people i'm not
interested and i don't have
i don't have a you know i don't have the
desire to be like no there's only
biological men and biological women and
da da
da not interested at all if you have a
your own pronoun you're probably an
annoying person anyway so i don't want
to hang out with you
so if someone came to me and said i
actually i met someone at occupied they
said you know uh
z said refer to me as z zer and i was
like i don't know i don't care whatever
sure
i just you know i just i just called by
that by their name some of these people
also made up their
own names and i'm like if you're 25 and
you're like
my name is you know hamsters you know
hamster friend i'm like
you sure yeah i'll call you whatever you
want i'm just like did i hear you right
all right you got it hamster bro
exactly i'll call you whatever you want
but i will call you very infrequently
if i have right i i remember this was
funny because it became a thing and some
people were like
they were like i don't know that's kind
of i've never never heard that like
we're supposed to remember that and i
was like
oh you ain't gonna forget you know i was
just like i'm sitting there like my eyes
half closed like it's like occupy while
i'm outside i'm sleeping outside i'm
like this is the last thing i care about
i was like dude i will call you whatever
you want you can call me susan if it
makes you happy i literally don't care
this is like the last thing on my mind
the cops are burning their horns right
now i'm gonna go get cheeseburger
i it like didn't even occur to me until
it started becoming a thing and now the
new york times was writing about it
and it's amazing because they mentioned
that like apparently someone a long time
ago tried to make
it the pronoun for like nondescript
individuals i guess
and they're they're look they're saying
like it's a new thing with young people
you have to respect it otherwise you're
like transphobic and all that stuff i'm
like
dude like a young woman who identifies
as a woman but calls herself like
you know gord and gordo and gordo self
like
that's not anything to do with like
transgender anything no
you know the idea that
there are there is a a significant
portion of the trans community
that actually does have their own
specific pronouns if i understand
correctly
the vast majority of the trans community
out there just wants to pass
they just want to be like if you're a
trans woman you just want to be
you just want to pass and you want to be
called she i totally respect that if
you're a trans man
you just want to pass you want to be
called heat totally respect that
that's totally fine i again i'm not
interested in
in demanding that someone go by the
pronouns of their you know of what they
were born as like that or what they were
assigned at birth or whatever i i'm not
interested in in messing up someone's
day like that
um and so i think that it's really
mostly activists and people that are
that are looking to or i think it's
mostly activists that are looking to
make
a specific uh personalized pronoun
or or something that is is unique or
whatever and it's like
okay i mean you can and again if i if if
you have
pronouns that you need me to use i'll
use them but i'm probably gonna be like
this person is a lot of work to be
around yeah yeah
uh i think one of the issues is that
there's no way to broach the subject
without being
accused of being transphobic because
there's actually two different
transgender communities
or i should say two two different trans
uh perspectives on this
there are some prominent trans uh people
who mention
that they view gender as binary hence
they're transitioning between male or
female yep they
they'll say there's like degrees in
between or something but for the most
part
i think it's like the millennial and
older transgender people some prominent
leftists i'm not going to name them
because
they've already got canceled several
times but they've pointed out
that uh they believe there's he she
and if you want to go by that's fine
what happened was this particular trans
woman
got cancelled because the younger
generation said you're being transphobic
for not respecting neo pronouns
natalie i'm not gonna say who i'm not
gonna i don't wanna i don't wanna cause
a dragging thing where they're like look
at this video and he called this person
and
made all these things up so you know he
said this about this person and they go
into a brigade no i don't wanna get
involved in that
i just want to point out the difference
here's what they say at the new york
times
they say one card explains neopronouns
at length
in its facts section it provides a
response used often in the neo-pronoun
community
when talking to people who claim
neo-pronouns aren't real words
yes literally every word is made up neo
pronouns are real
because they carry meaning and are
understood by others that's
the problem they're not i don't
understand half these words and if you
said it to me i'd be like i don't know
what that is i don't
know what you're trying to tell me if
someone said
they were their pronouns were pre-print
i'd be like
i don't understand like that that
doesn't mean anything to me and
and like you're saying part of the part
of the usefulness of words is the
meaning behind them
if so the issue becomes
neo-pronouns just get rid of pronouns in
general because if
ian tells me his pronouns are pre-prin
and so instead of saying
you know he said he was mad at himself
i'd say
pre said pre was mad at prince self
it's harder to understand what i'm
saying and think about it and
communicate
maybe that's on purpose maybe they're
trying to exert power maybe these are
young people who want
to you know assert themselves in a
conversation but if
if everyone here gave me a different
pronoun i wouldn't be able to be like oh
i was talking to ian yeah priest said
that uh prince
yeah he was saying he wanted to go to
the mall because he was mad at himself
for not buying
you know his uh his second set of shot
glasses which part of the
which is part of the point that i made
about you know i'll i'll say whatever
you want me to say for your pronoun but
it is difficult
to engage with you if you have your own
specific pronouns because there's a
certain amount of
you know when you read you just
you don't re sound out the words that
you know the word
and so you see the word you identify it
and it does you know
you know what it says because you're
familiar with the whole word
and our brains work like that when it
comes to talking too
we don't have to think about the words
we're going to use
you have to think about the idea and
maybe how to articulate it but you're
not thinking about how do i say
this if you have a new word in your
lexicon
or if there's a special word for a
person you have to really put thought
thought into it so it does become an
awkward way of speaking it's like
telling you four names
but now not one thing that's happening
where the left is getting angry is
people started calling themselves their
pronouns are blm and blm self
so you'd be you'd be like oh i was
talking to ian blm said that
blm was mad at blm self for not buying
blm's
second whiskey said whiskey glasses
i get it and they're doing a cab and a
capsule
oh good good so i'm glad
thank you i love it all right well i'm
going to read more
many people who use neopronouns don't
just use one set they suck
a handful and show off their collections
on websites like pronoun
pronounie.xyz a site that provides usage
examples
for neo pronouns users make their own
pronony pages like this one which
includes
z zemser moon moon self star star self b
b self and bun bun self
sorry if i have too many pronouns the
page creators wrote one self is
from now on call me bun bun self okay
it's mine now
i do like bun self but like basically
for rabbits not for anybody else okay
that'd be cute yeah yeah bun
bun wanted you know bun was telling me
bun wanted more carrots for oneself
i love it you can use you can use just
one set
or they them if there are too many
so here's where it gets interesting i
know a lot of people think this is silly
i'm down for respecting people within
certain contexts
you know behind closed doors we have to
make fun of each other we don't like not
everybody likes each other but we try to
be good to each other to the best of our
abilities at least i think that's a good
thing
you're out in public you see someone you
don't like you smile and you nod then
you go behind closed door and say they
smell like farts whatever
of course so if someone comes up to me
and they're like my protons but you got
it you know i got i got no beef but
if i'm not hanging out with you i'm
gonna be like i mean i i i think this
here's why i think it becomes a problem
many states are passing these laws that
say
your company these jobs have to use your
pronouns
that's it it's in the law i actually i
i'm you know what i'ma stop
i like this i'm a fan you know why this
is legit culture jamming
this is exploiting the system and
pointing out the holes and how they
don't work
so in new york you are entitled at your
job
or as a customer to have your pronouns
your name respected
it's a civil it's a human rights law in
new york city if you work at say
you know starbucks and you demand to
have a certain set of pronouns
they have to use them otherwise they're
violating your human rights it's a
violation of your gender expression
okay so to what limit if the new york
times is straight up saying you can use
50 different pronouns
your manager better start doing it so
i'm like okay let's play that game let's
i i encourage people to adopt pronouns
that they feel comfortable with
and make something of it i guess i you
know i
i get what you're saying but i i think
that that
eventually uh and probably very quickly
will become
detrimental to the to the actual trans
community because
the more difficult you make it for
people to
navigate polite society the less
interested people will be in being
polite
they're gonna say well it's just too
much of a pain in the dick so
pardon my french and they're just gonna
be like you know
screw it i'm just gonna do you know
whatever i'm not worried about this
person's
you know blah blah and then actual you
know people that
that have trained you know have
transitioned that you know genuinely do
get their feelings hurt if they're
misgendered and stuff like that they're
going to be the people that are going to
pay the price
yeah you know and i think that that
there are there is a certain
to some to a certain degree there are
people that will do
things like have their own pronouns
their own personal pronouns
for a narcissistic reason and they're
going to hurt actual trans people and
they're gonna they're gonna end up
making it bad for people that are you
know actually trans
i've actually mentioned this i was
telling the story about new york when
the story first
was breaking it was like a few months
after the law was passed
i started exploring what new york city
had said in terms of
pronouns and they said any any and so i
actually
talked i reached out some friends i said
i need to find a human rights lawyer
like someone who
litigates and like actually understands
this and some advocates and
there's a lot of confusion but i spoke
with one lawyer who basically said
if you tried gaming the system and
making up some ridiculous pronoun
they would laugh you out of court and i
was like so if i went to a restaurant
and i used some ridiculous like asian
stereotype for like me and my family
and you know just like offensive words i
and they said i refuse to say these
things you think if i sued the judge
would say
get out of here you're screwing with us
i think i disagree totally but well so
this lawyer said
there's a reason why we have laws and we
have judges judges interpret the law
if the judge sees that you're making a
mockery of the law
they will just say oh we get it it's not
legitimate complaint
and then i said so you're saying if i
dress in a way that is deemed to be
a joke or illegitimate the judge can
just throw me out and he goes yes and i
said
so what happens if an actual trans
person walks up to a judge and the judge
says you're not a woman
and then says get out of my courtroom
that that opens the door for them to
actually
suppress transgender rights and that's
when the lawyer was like
well you know these things like the
general idea from the lawyer was
it's true they could happen but
most of these judges understand the
spirit of the law
and i was like listen i'm willing to bet
there's going to be a conservative judge
in one of these jurisdictions
and if you're telling me they have a
right to laugh someone out of the
courtroom it will be an actual trans
person
yep yeah i guess especially if you're
looking at people now who are becoming
aggravated by
the excessivity of it uh they become
judges in the future
you know the right 17 year olds now are
going to be judges in 20 years i don't i
don't and the thing is i don't know
that it's actually really
excessive i think that things like that
story again
are such a small case like there are
such a
very few people that would want to be
you think that you think that it would
be more than do you think i was i was
just gonna
i physically express myself while you're
talking just so you know i'm gonna have
a counterpoint but uh
this is from tumblr 10 years ago it's
now in the new york times it is
but i still don't think that there's a
lot of people that that would be using
their own personalized
because i mean we already talked about
the fact that most trans people just
want to pass
yeah and they just want to be they want
to live their life
as you know as as a trans woman or as a
trans man that's that's
that's it i and i think that the a
very small minority want the specialized
uh you know specialized pronouns and i
do think that that
is more about narcissism
than about actually being transgender i
think that it's more about i want to be
you know i want attention i think you
hit the nail on that with this one that
it's ultimately going to be
more detrimental for trans people yeah i
think it's a hard trance community
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time